news daily from science mission
scientist in the journal Cell dissect
the lifespan extension pathway in
drosophila they demonstrate that
downstream of the insulin receptor
substrate Chico signaling bifurcates
into two branches rassee RK and pi3k akt
at the transcription level these two
branches subsequently rejoined acting on
a Opie and fox or transcription factors
in a nonnegative manner authors were
able to extend lifespan of flies using
an incident mutant or vas inhibitors or
using a drug trametinib that
specifically blocks Russ crk pathway
which is conserved in many species and
thus rass pathway could be a useful
target to increase lifespan next also
interleukin 21 has been associated with
chronic HIV control its contribution to
early HIV community is not known now
researchers show that interleukin 21
acts on stat promoters increases
transcription of all micro RNA 29 which
in turn block HIV replication and thus
suggests a role for interleukin 21 in
initial hiv-1 control for more news
visitors as www science mission calm or
science mission Facebook page thanks for
watching